the environment really matters if you're
in a really negative environment you got
people telling you you can't do things
you got family members friends people at
school people at work I understand most
people hate their lives most people are
not out living their best life it's not
even that they're negative or toxic
people I don't believe in haters or
people are bad they're just people who
are in a lot of pain and when you're in
a lot of pain you do stupid things like
when you and I were in pain we might
have been rude to somebody it doesn't
mean you're a bad person you're just
dealing with a lot of pain and if you
look at most people they're dealing with
a lot of pain in their lives you'd
expect somebody in pain to lash out if
you're around all these people all the
time that start to seep into you who's
the most negative person in your life or
or news source or media Source or
whatever and just sub that person out or
limit access